in this video i take the super low light
camera that shoots at 4.5 million iso
out on a midnight shoot
[Music]
this film was made possible by my good
friends in epidemic sound which is the
greatest sound and music library on the
internet
[Music]
all of the below totals to 31 091 us
dollars this is the canon me 20f sh and
was brought out about six years ago it
said some pretty interesting reviews
inside this thing is beast we're not
just talking low light
this camera can shoot in almost no
lights 4.6 million iso what does that
even mean and since then nothing but
still no other camera out there to this
day can shoot up to 4.56 million iso
however this one-of-a-kind camera does
come with a few limitations like how
it's only limited to shooting up to
1080p at a maximum of 60 frames per
second and that recording is only
possible if you have an external
recording device like an atomos ninja
there's also limited controls on the
camera meaning that you'll need a remote
to unlock its full features it is also
compatible with all of canon's cinema
lenses and most of their photographic
lenses too this camera was designed to
capture clear well exposed video in full
color in the darkest of environments so
yeah in this video i'm going to be
putting this camera to the test and to
see how far we can really go
the sun is starting to set and i'm on my
way to the beach i've always wanted to
shoot surfing at night
the manfrotto is going to brave the cold
the wind and the tiny waves and most
probably the sharks
[Music]
problem with this camera it's got so
many parts to make it work
all this other [ __ ] comes together to
make that camera see in the dark
[Music]
through these waves
i just don't know how are you gonna see
anything
you're gonna help me i will
we are currently shooting in complete
black
[Music]
i'll tell you one thing though it is
[ __ ] grainy
well what we've learned is the camera
can't see in complete darkness it was
super grainy but what i'm going to do is
i'm going to use this torch and i'm
going to use it to light the wave
i'm just operating the torch takes
extreme precision therefore i've got
liam on the camera okay you got this
in this case i reckon it's the easier
job
i must say manfred's brave there we go
that looks so sick
[Music]
[Music]
that was not easy got another night
shoot tomorrow so i'm just gonna go to
the studio charge all the gear and then
go home and get some rest
we are on our way to the cedarburg
mountains which is three hours outside
of cape town it has the most incredible
stars pretty excited it should be good
[Music]
we have chosen the worst two nights to
do this review
wind wise
it's called ah
[Music]
but star wise which is a really good
night it is insane out here
this camera just seems to keep giving
it's really good
you can literally see galaxies
that's honestly unreal let's have a look
at this footage
[Music]
so
[Music]
while looking at this epic footage i
wanted to take the time to tell you more
about epidemic sound firstly if you
didn't know before epidemic sound is the
greatest of all time sound and music
library on the internet the whole way
through this video especially in the
montage scenes like the one you're
watching now i have made use of sound
and music that really helps amplify the
visual and i get all my sound effects
from the super easy to navigate epidemic
library and if i find a sound that i
like but it's not quite what i was
looking for i can click the find similar
button which allows me to see what
sounds in the same realm of what i was
looking for epidemic sound has also
built an ecosystem to let artists music
producers and composers thrive
creatively and commercially i have
linked them below so go sign up today i
promise you that your sounded music game
will just go up and up so yeah what are
your thoughts on the canon
me20f sh besides its ridiculously long
and complicated name is the effort along
with the hefty price tag as well as all
the other bits and bobs you have to add
to the camera worth the footage let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
as well as what camera you would like me
to try next other than that don't forget
you're awesome bru and i'll see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you